[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
FRANK SCHILBACH: So I'm
going to briefly recap
what we discussed,
and then sort of talk
about a number of different
applications, ranging from,
like, work, exercising, credit
cards, savings behavior,
drinking, smoking,
fertilizer use, and so on.
And then, that'll spill
into the next lecture,
or go into next lecture as well.
I'm going to sort of
summarize where we are.
What do we know about
time preferences?
What have you learned?
What's useful from what have
you learned for the world,
and what things might be
still up for investigation?
OK, so what happened
so far is, like,
I showed you a simple model
of exponential discounting.
Again, that's the workhorse
model of discounting.
In economics, it's one of
the most successful and most
important models that
people have written down.
In economics, the Solow model,
et cetera, like, many sort
of different important models,
thinking about long-run growth
and so on, use this
particular model.
So it's been tremendously
important and successful.
It has different implications
that we discussed
at length, both in
class, and lecture,
and in recitation, which
is constant discounting,
dynamic consistency, and
no demand for commitment.
We discussed some
evidence that shows
that these assumptions--
these implications--
are not warranted.
And then we talked about
a different version
of this model, or like an
extension, if you want,
of that model, which is the
quasi-hyperbolic discounting
model, which adds an additional
parameter that measures
people's present bias
or present focus,
as people call it sometimes
these days, which allows us
to be more flexible
and be able to look
at short-run and long-run
discounting in the same model,
as in, like, there is one
parameter, beta, that measures
people's short-run discount
factor, and another parameter,
delta, which is
close to one off,
and that measures the
long-run discount factor.
That makes the
model more flexible,
and we're able to explain
some phenomena that might
be hard to explain otherwise.
Any questions on that so far,
or last time, or the like?
OK, so then next, we talked
about sophistication versus
naiveté.
So this is the issue
that we discussed before,
which is present bias creates
time inconsistency, right?
When thinking about the
future, we want to be patient.
When the time actually comes,
when the future actually
arrived, we are impatient.
So then the key question you
might ask is, like, well,
do people understand
the time consistency?
We talked about two different
extreme assumptions or versions
if this.
One is full naiveté, which is
the idea that the person does
not realize that she
will change her mind.
When thinking about
the future, she
thinks she's going to follow
through on her favorite plan.
When the future comes,
she will be patient.
But then of course, the future
arrives and surprises happen.
And the person is surprised
by their own present bias.
And sort of there is false
optimism about future patience,
and sort of the--
over and over again,
the person might say,
this time is different.
Second extreme assumption
is full sophistication.
That is perfect foresight.
The person actually understands
their beta perfectly well,
and understands that
she, in the future,
might not stick to the
plans that she has,
and might change her mind.
So she does sort of her
best, given the future self's
anticipated changes in behavior.
So taken into account
as a constraint what
the person will
do in the future,
the person optimizes that way.
There's no surprises
about future present bias.
The person has
rational expectations.
Those are the two broad extreme
assumptions that we discussed.
Now, how can we tell--
how can we actually tell--
so if you wanted to
know about your friend,
and try to understand, is this
person naive or sophisticated,
how can we actually tell
whether that's the case?
What do we do?
What data could you collect
from your friend or from people
that you see?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Just giving
them [INAUDIBLE]..
Trying to see, like, what they
procrastinate [INAUDIBLE]..
FRANK SCHILBACH: And what
exactly would you collect?
AUDIENCE: I guess if
you could, asking them
what they think that
they're going to do,
and then seeing what
they actually do.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right,
so one thing you can do
is collect the person's beliefs.
So you can ask them, what are
you going to do in the future?
And if the person mispredicts
what they're going to be
in the future-- in particular,
if the person thinks
they're going to be more
patient in the future than they
actually are, so if they think
their beta in the future is
higher than it actually is,
that would suggest at least some
naiveté, right?
What else could we elicit?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: There are
some choices that people
make that wouldn't make
sense if they're not
being sophisticated.
So for example, is we see
them restricting their choices
in some way that we would
expect a sophisticated person--
like that would make sense
if they're [INAUDIBLE] naive.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Exactly,
so if you offered them
commitment devices, and we said,
here's a commitment device.
You can change your
future behavior
in certain ways that make
certain behaviors in the future
more expensive.
So for example, you
might tell your friend,
or your friend
might offer to you,
if I don't do the problem
set until Friday, 5:00 PM,
because you want
to have fun Friday
night, I'm going
to pay you $100.
Now, if you make that choice,
or if somebody offers you
that option to pay
them $100 in case
you haven't done the problem set
by Friday 5:00 PM, that choice
does make doesn't make
any sense if the person is
an exponential discounter.
That person only makes sense
if you are a present bias
or if you have self-control
problems in some way.
And you must be
sophisticated in some sense.
So it must indicate some
form of sophistication.
To be clear, it doesn't
indicate perfect sophistication.
You might be only
partially sophisticated.
But at least it indicates
some form of sophistication.
I'm going to talk about partial
sophistication in a bit.
The same awareness
issue does not
arise with exponential
discounting.
Why is that?
So in some sense, if you
thought about it, like,
if you have looked at like the
exponential discounting model,
there's nothing about
sophistication and naiveté.
There's no parameter
that measures that.
And why is that?
Why do we need like a
delta hat, or whatever?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right, exactly.
So the whole issue only
arises because there's
time and consistency.
The future self wants
different things
that the current self does.
In the exponential discounting
model, there's no such issue.
There's no time and consistency.
So the future self
will always do
what the current self
actually wants to do
unless circumstances change.
So we don't need any parameter
that sort of looks at,
like, how much is
the future self
deviating, because
that's not even
an issue in the first place.
OK, so then we talked about
sort of extreme assumptions.
So these are extreme
assumptions on the two ends.
One is, like, full naiveté.
You're entirely naive.
You just cannot imagine that
your beta in the future will be
different from one.
That's full naiveté.
And then there is the
other extreme assumption,
which is full sophistication,
which is beta hat
equals beta, right?
Essentially, it's like you
understand entirely what's
going on with your future beta.
But of course, there's a whole
range in between from beta to 1
that beta hat could take.
And that's what we refer
to as partial naiveté.
That is to say beta hat measures
the beliefs about future beta.
The extreme cases are
useful to think about.
But presumably, the truth
is somewhere in between.
So the intermediate
case might be
sort of the most
relevant one, which
is beta hat is in
between beta and 1.
So that is to say,
the individual
understands that they will
experience present bias
in the future.
So I know that I have some
present bias in the future.
As an example, say,
my beta might be 0.6.
I might think-- I
understand to some degree
that my future beta is not 1.
But I might think it's
like 0.8 or the like.
So I understand that I will
be present bias in the future,
but I underestimate the degree
of present bias in the future.
And so if I'm partially naive--
and this is what Maya was
saying earlier--
I might demand commitment
devices anyway.
I might understand I have
a problem in the future.
So I want some
commitment devices.
But I could also overcommit.
I could demand
commitment devices that
are actually not useful for me.
Why is that?
Because I sort of
underestimate how bad
my self-control problem is.
I understand there's a
self-control problem.
Somebody offers me a commitment
device that's fairly weak.
I say great, that's
going to help me.
That's going to help
me follow through.
But then, surprise, my
self-control problem
is actually worse
than I anticipated.
And then I have a
commitment device
and I'm actually failing
with that commitment device,
because the self-control
problem happens
to be worse than anticipated.
Any questions on this?
OK, we're going to talk
tomorrow about, like--
a little bit about solving
problems with partial naiveté.
We talked about solving problems
with full naiveté and full
sophistication.
Partial naiveté is a
little bit trickier,
because it sort of
requires iterating forwards
and backwards.
We'll talk about this
briefly tomorrow.
OK, so now, demand for
commitment, we already
talked about this before.
Here is sort of a
formal definition.
It's defined as an arrangement
entered into by an agent who
restricts his and
her future choice set
by making certain choices more
expensive, perhaps infinitely
expensive.
That's to say, at the
margin, you might sort of
pay for something that might
make restrict your choices
or make your choices in
the future more expensive.
If it's not
available at all, you
can think of this as, like,
the price is infinite, right?
So I don't want to
eat donuts tomorrow.
I can make donuts
more expensive--
more and more expensive.
If it's infinitely
expensive, donuts
are just not available to me.
So now of course,
as we said before,
time-inconsistent preferences,
the selves differ.
And this is, again, repetition.
Selfs differ between
what you want today
versus in the future.
You might sort of worry about
misbehaving in the future.
If you understand
that, you might
want to discipline your future
self by demanding a commitment
device.
OK, so who of you is using
commitment devices, or can
you give me an example
of a commitment device
that you have used in the
past, successful or not?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I have an app on my
phone where I can set a timer
[INAUDIBLE].
FRANK SCHILBACH: Does it work?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
FRANK SCHILBACH:
I should try that.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I have a
browser extension
that launch certain sites
at certain times of the day.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Does
it work for you, too?
AUDIENCE: Somewhat.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Why
does it not work?
AUDIENCE: Because it's way
too easy to just turn it off.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right, exactly.
So that's an example
of a commitment device
that's sort of
partial in some ways.
It's not sort of strong enough.
So either you can
sort of substitute
to, like, Firefox or whatever,
and another browser, you
can substitute your phone, you
can substitute your friend's
phone even, and so on.
Or you might just actually be
able to turn it off yourself.
But you can circumvent.
I think there's some apps that
have sort of options that don't
allow you to do that at all.
But you guys are, like,
a lot of CS majors.
So maybe you can get
around that as well.
Any other examples?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: When you go shopping,
buying more vegetables
or something so that
you feel like, oh, I
have to eat them, otherwise I
just wasted my time and money.
FRANK SCHILBACH: So what
do you do actually then?
So what's your
commitment device?
AUDIENCE: I guess it's
like making the choice
to eat something else,
like, more expensive.
Because I'd have to, like,
go back to the grocery store
and I'd have to pay for it.
FRANK SCHILBACH: But
how do you commit then?
Or, like, what's
restricting your options?
AUDIENCE: The fact
that I'm lazy and I
don't want to go somewhere
to get other food.
FRANK SCHILBACH:
But, like, so you
know that you're going to do
that in the future potentially.
So now, how do you avoid or
change your future behavior?
Can you sort of
incentivize yourself?
Or can you make sure that--
another version of that
would be, like, so
what people often
do is when they buy,
for example, potato
chips or the like, they buy
really small bags, in part
sort of knowing that if they buy
a big bag, which actually would
be cheaper, they
would just eat it all.
So then, you have, like,
only very small portions.
And then if you
want another one,
you have to sort of go to
the store and buy more.
So that's like a
version-- it's sort
of a version of a commitment
device, where essentially, you
commit yourself to, if you
want to eat more potato
chips in the future,
you have to go back
to the store as opposed
to having, like,
a big bag that you can just
consume in one session.
Yeah.
Any other examples?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Carrying
cash instead of card.
Like, if you [INAUDIBLE] cash
on you, you won't overspend.
FRANK SCHILBACH: I see.
And so that's interesting.
Yeah, exactly.
So, like, credit,
it's interesting.
Because in some sense,
in some other settings,
carrying cash is
sort of not helping.
But you're saying, like, instead
of having a credit card where
you can spend, usually, as much
as you like, depending on what
your credit limit
is, you might say,
I'm going to go out with
$100, and, like, once I've
spent the $100, I'm not
going to spend more.
I have to sort of go
back home or the like.
And then, I might sort of
not give in to temptations.
The reason I was
hesitating a little bit
is, like, in
developing countries,
in part, in some settings
where I work, lots of people
have lots of cash on
hand from their work.
For example, cycle
rickshaw drivers,
they would have a
lot of cash on hand
because they get, like, trips--
they get paid for
every single trip.
And then they have
lots of cash on hand.
It's actually quite bad,
because then they can spend it
on lots of things any day.
And having it in a liquid,
or their savings account
or the like, would be a
different form of commitment
device that might help them.
There was more-- yes?
AUDIENCE: There's a
show, Nathan For You,
where he wants to help
people lose weight.
So he takes a picture of
them-- like a very embarrassing
picture--
and gets a notarized letter
that gets sent out in two weeks
if they don't lose five pounds.
FRANK SCHILBACH:
And does it work?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
[LAUGHTER]
FRANK SCHILBACH:
Wow, interesting.
I've not heard of this.
What is it called?
AUDIENCE: That's how
embarrassing the picture is.
FRANK SCHILBACH: I see.
Yeah, you can see, like--
yeah, it depends a
little bit, I guess--
yeah, so when asked does it
work, does it work on average,
or what's being
shown, or how costly
is it to fail--
but it sounds like,
at least for some people,
that's, in fact, effective.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: There are
some accounts where
you can put money,
and it's a bit harder
to take that money
out [INAUDIBLE]..
So that's kind of [INAUDIBLE]
and you can take it out
[INAUDIBLE].
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right.
AUDIENCE: If you really
need it [INAUDIBLE]..
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right, in fact,
a lot of retirement accounts
in the US, in many places, have
penalties for early withdrawal.
It's a lot of, like, many
employers that offer 401(k)
and other savings vehicles--
essentially, that's like
a retirement sort of--
tax-deferred retirement savings
often sort of subsidized
by the employer.
But often, one condition is
that you have to pay a 10%,
or something, penalty
to withdraw it.
Similarly, I think for
some savings accounts,
that's sort of similar.
And the idea is very much, like,
helping you resist temptations
to change your plan.
So you're going to plan
for saving for retirement
or something else.
But in fact, you might
sort of withdraw early
if you're tempted.
And then usually,
the penalty is only
something like 10% or the like.
Because when people have actual
shocks, like health shocks
or other issues, they want
to be able to take out
the money at some penalty.
So they don't want
to have it to be
entirely liquid, because
that would be bad for them.
Any other example?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I have an
alarm clock on my phone
where I have to take a
picture of something.
So I'll get up, and
go to the bathroom,
and take a picture of the thing.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Does it work?
AUDIENCE: No, I take the
picture and I go back to bed.
FRANK SCHILBACH: I
see, fair enough.
Does it work sometimes?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, kind of.
FRANK SCHILBACH:
Sometimes, I see.
Yeah, so there the
issue, in some sense,
is, like, if it
doesn't work, then
you're kind of worse
off than before,
because you slept worse than
you would have otherwise.
And you know, there's no benefit
of you getting actually up.
Yeah.
One more?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Would, like,
societally implied commitment
about-- it's like,
No Shave November,
would some sort of
variance on that work?
FRANK SCHILBACH:
Of what, exactly?
AUDIENCE: Like No Shave
November or variants of this,
would that imply a
commitment device?
FRANK SCHILBACH: Yeah, I
mean, I think in some sense,
there's often--
some commitment devices are
essentially sort of public
attention or the like, where
people are announcing one way
or the other publicly-- which
is kind of what you were saying
earlier--
where society, in some sense,
has some influence where people
would say they would
publicly declare that they're
going to lose weight.
They would publicly declare that
they're going to save money,
and so on.
And then, there would
be social shaming
in some way or the
other to do that.
Now, what you want--
so in some sense,
if it's just society
imposing things on people,
that's not enough.
What you want is
a person actively
sort of making some
announcement or some statements
with a goal of making it more
costly not to follow through.
OK, so as I said before,
demand for commitment
requires at least some
partial sophistication.
I have some examples
for you here.
One is, like, StickK.
I don't know if you
have any of-- has
any of you used StickK?
No?
OK, so StickK is a website
founded by an academic, Dean
Karlan and co-authors.
What StickK does is,
it's a commitment device
that works, in some sense, in
the way I was saying before.
For example, if you want to of
commit to certain behaviors,
for example, if I
wanted to finish a paper
draft by Friday night, I
would have to find a referee.
I would, for example, ask
Aaron to be my referee.
And I would say, Aaron,
I'm going to give you
my credit card information.
And if I don't finish the
paper by Friday night,
I'm going to pay $100 either
to Aaron or to some charity--
could be anti charity, could be
the pro-smoking, pro-whatever
society.
The money is going to be gone.
And so then, Friday night comes.
Aaron is the referee who
can then decide, or will
decide, then, whether I have
actually followed through.
Did I actually write a draft?
Is there an actual
paper that's done?
And if it's done,
then nothing happens.
I don't have to pay any money.
If it's not done,
the money is gone.
And since the credit card
information is on the website,
they can actually just
withdraw that money.
What's the problem with this
commitment device, potentially?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: The referee not
wanting to enforce it?
FRANK SCHILBACH: Yes, exactly.
So, like, I tried to do
this a few times in school.
And my friend was my referee.
And then, Friday
night would come.
And then I would sort of just
convince my friend to, like--
I'll pay you dinner with
if you let me get through.
So you need a very
good friend who
is actually sort
of then insisting,
and sort of credible,
potentially.
Or your enemy could be your
referee, if you wanted,
who is happy sort of
then to take your money.
But I think it's worth trying.
You can try it out and
see whether it works.
I'd love to hear some thoughts
on whether it works or not.
There's Clocky which I
think is coming out of MIT.
It's an alarm clock
that runs away,
which is kind of similar to
what you mentioned earlier.
There's also Tocky, which is the
alarm clock that jumps around,
and then you have
to sort of find it.
[LAUGHTER]
There are some forms of--
this is a fake alarm clock--
I don't think it actually
exists-- where essentially,
if you don't get up and
press a button on your alarm,
you essentially give
money to charity
or anti-charities if you want.
There's a thing called Antabuse,
which is quite interesting,
which is a drug that
essentially interferes
with the metabolism of alcohol.
So this is some people
have trouble metabolizing
alcohol anyway.
So when they drink, they flush.
They turn-- they get headaches.
They have to throw up, and
feel unwell, and so on.
So for them, drinking is
very unpleasant as it is.
It turns out,
there's a drug that
can actually sort of reproduce
those kinds of behaviors
or feelings.
And it's essentially--
you can take it.
And then for the
next 24 to 48 hours,
you will not be able
to metabolize alcohol.
There's also
versions of that that
are sort of implants
for a month or the like.
But essentially, they
make alcohol consumption
very unpleasant.
And this is sort of
meant to help people
who have problems with
alcohol consumption,
that if you don't want
to drink tomorrow,
or in two days from now, or
the like, or the next month,
you can take it and then
commit to not doing that.
And then alcohol consumption
becomes very unpleasant
when consuming alcohol anyway.
It's a little bit dangerous.
Or it can be quite dangerous
if people then drink anyway,
because there's sort
of an alcohol antabuse
sort of reaction
that's quite dangerous.
So it hasn't been
particularly successful,
in part also because people
sort of fall off the bandwagon.
So if you essentially
take that daily, or, like,
every second day,
what happens then
is that people start
wanting to drink.
And then they just stop
taking the Antabuse.
And then they have
to sort of just
wait it out for 24
hours or the like
until the drug is
out of their system.
And then they drink anyway.
But in principle, it's like
the ideal commitment device.
Because essentially,
the only reason for you
to take this drug would be to
reduce your future drinking.
There's also sort of various
versions of self-control
devices which essentially either
restrict certain websites that
you can go to--
you can restrict yourself--
or it restricts them
to certain hours, or you
can sort of give yourself
a budget for a number
of hours that you
can use certain websites for.
Any questions?
So I also have a video
of commitment devices,
which I'm not sure whether
the audio actually works.
So we have to try this out.
If not, I'll show
it to you tomorrow.
OK, so as you can see,
I think we can learn
a lot from watching movies.
And I love TV.
So what can we learn from this?
I think that it can actually--
we can learn a lot about sort
of commitment devices,
and whether they work,
and why they work, or
why they might not work.
So what did what did we learn?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] reversible
commitment devices are not
as effective.
FRANK SCHILBACH:
Right, so just making,
like, future choices more
expensive might not be enough,
right?
I might sort of say I might
have self-control problems.
Now, I'm going to increase the
price of my future behavior.
But that doesn't mean
that it actually works.
It might just be more costly.
Now, I have to climb up
the ladder or whatever.
But then I might still eat the
cookie, and that's not helping.
What else did we learn?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: But I think you
have to find a balance.
Because if you make
the penalty too high,
you're not going to use
the commitment device.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right, exactly.
So what they did, essentially,
they made the penalty--
or they essentially
made the price
of cookies infinitely high.
They just sort of gave
them away to the birds.
Now they don't have any cookies
at all, and sort of now,
they're going to eat
no cookies whatsoever,
which is kind of not what
they wanted either, right?
AUDIENCE: But I think
another lesson is that once
you've made one of
these commitment devices
so costly that you
actually just transfer it
to another temptation
[INAUDIBLE]..
FRANK SCHILBACH: Yes, exactly.
That's what I was
saying earlier.
You might sort of
restrict your browser.
You might sort of, like,
shut down Chrome, or even
your entire laptop.
But then, if you start
surfing on your phone,
that's not really helping.
So in some sense there's,
like, substitution
to different potential either
sort of goods, or devices,
and so on, or technologies
that might sort of undo
your commitment device.
So they need to be foolproof
in some sense, in the sense of,
like, being able to not
substitute to other things.
OK, so first, substitution
across temptation goods
can mitigate the
usefulness of commitment.
If, essentially, you have
other vices or other things
you're going to do
instead, then it's not
really helpful to shut
down one thing only.
So you have to think about, if
I don't do the behavior that I'm
trying to prevent, is there
sort of other behaviors
that am I going to
substitute towards,
and then it's not going
to be helpful either?
Now, it's also helpful to think
about what is it actually--
what is it actually required
for a commitment device
to be helpful to a person?
So first, kind of obviously
in some ways, the person
needs to have some self-control
problem in the first place.
This needs to be something that,
in the future, some behavior
you want to change.
Second, there needs to be
some sophistication, right?
Like Frog and Toad,
they kind of know
that they're going to
eat too many cookies.
They need to sort
of understand that.
Third, and this is
what was said earlier,
the commitment device
needs to be effective.
We need to have something
that's sort of strong enough
to be able to help us overcome
our self-control problems.
And then fourth,
it needs to be--
the person needs
to actually think
that the device is effective.
If I sort of don't
have faith in myself,
I think this is not useful, then
I'm never going to take it up.
Or conversely, I guess, there's
issues potentially with, like,
naiveté.
There's two things
that naiveté could do.
So one part in naiveté--
what I was already
talking about before--
which is to say, I might
be naive in a sense
I'm saying, like, I know--
I don't have-- if I'm
fully naive, I might think,
I don't have a
self-control problem.
It's not really bad.
So I don't really need
a commitment device
in the first place.
That's one version where I
sort of under demand commitment
by saying I don't
actually need it.
It's not helpful for me anyway.
In the future, I will behave.
So I might not
demand commitment.
Another version is to
say, I might actually
demand commitment devices where
I overcommit myself in a sense,
like, I think the commitment
device is actually helpful
when in fact it is not.
So Frog and Toad
were not doing that.
In some sense, they
sort of like understood,
to some degree at least,
pretty well what they're
going to do in the future.
I think they sort of
underestimated the substitution
in this case, in the
sense of, like, they
thought giving the cookies to
the birds would be helpful.
But in fact, then they
sort of underestimated
the substitution.
And in the end, you know,
they're going to be worse off.
Because now, he's going to
make the cake anyway, and then
eat a lot of cake.
He could have as well just eaten
the cookies in the first place.
Any questions on this?
OK, so now, let me sort of turn
toward some academic papers,
and sort of actual
empirical setups.
So this is the paper that
you, I hope, all read,
which is Ariely and Wertenbroch.
Dan Ariely was actually a
professor here at Sloan,
and did a bunch of experiments,
mostly with MIT students
at Sloan--
MBAs.
And so these are 51
executives at Sloan.
These are sort of highly
incentivized individuals,
in the sense that
they take classes,
and if they don't--
if they fail a class,
if they do badly in a class,
they have to actually pay
for it themselves.
So they really are
incentivized to do well.
They had to submit three
papers in their class
to get a 1% grade penalty
for late submissions, which
is quite a bit.
There were two groups.
Group A had
evenly-spaced deadlines.
Group B had the option to
set their own deadlines.
And now, the first
sort of result
here is that there was demand
for commitment in the sense
that, like, 68% of
people chose deadlines
prior to the last week.
So when given the
option when do you
want to set your deadlines over
the course of the semester,
68% of people chose deadlines
that were not the last week.
Why is that demand
for commitment?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: More
choices as to when
to do the paper, just to
make a deadline at the end.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Exactly,
like, you-- there's
no reason, unless you have sort
of issues with self-control
and the like, you just
make it essentially costly
for you to submit late.
If you are worried about
submitting everything late,
that's a good thing for you
to do, and it might help you.
Again, notice that it
requires some sophistication.
You need to sort of understand
your future behavior
to do that.
Now, what they
find is, like, they
find no late submissions,
which is interesting by itself.
But in particular, they find
that group A has higher grades
than group B, OK?
Group A is the group that
has evenly-spaced deadlines,
compared to group B
that has the option
to set their own deadlines.
It is consistent with
self-control problems,
in the sense that people
set their own deadlines that
are early.
What else is it consistent with?
What did we learn from that?
What do we learn from the
fact that group A does better
than group B?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: That the commitment
device wasn't strong enough?
FRANK SCHILBACH: Yeah, so in
some sense, the commitment
devices that people chose
for themselves was not
strong enough, or,
like, weaker than
the evenly-spaced deadlines.
Now, notice that
evenly-spaced deadlines are
in the choice set of people.
Like, if you choose your own
deadlines, you can just say,
I'm choosing
evenly-spaced deadlines.
And you should do as well-- if
you're perfectly sophisticated,
you would do as
well as the group A.
But the fact that the groups--
group B is doing worse sort of
tells us that people are not
optimally setting deadlines.
Either they don't-- there's
a fraction of people who
don't choose any deadlines.
There's at least 32% of
people who sort of say,
my deadlines are all at the end.
So maybe these are naive people.
Or even among the people
who set deadlines,
they might choose deadlines set
further back in the semester,
and they do worse than in
the evenly-spaced deadlines.
So what did we learn?
So people do set
early deadlines--
quite a few of them.
So we learn about people
are at least partially--
or some people
are sophisticated.
But they're only
partially sophisticated.
They don't set
deadlines optimally,
which is sort of consistent
with people being naive,
at least in some way.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I was
wondering, does it
make sense to try to find
the difference between not
adequately measuring your
commitment [INAUDIBLE]
estimating how long it would
take you to do the paper?
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right,
that's a great question.
So the question is, so
there's two things that
are perhaps uncertain when
you think about the future.
One is your present bias--
your preference parameter
about how much work
you're going to put
in today versus
tomorrow, and how much
you're going to procrastinate.
A second question is about
your beliefs about your effort
costs in some way
or the other, which
is how costly is it for you to
actually do the problem set,
or write the paper, and so on.
And you might underestimate
how tedious it is to do.
There's sort of a large
literature on what's
called the "planning fallacy."
People always plan
too many things,
and think whatever they plan
takes shorter than it actually
does.
Or put differently,
things always
take longer than people
think when they make plans.
And the odd thing is that
also is the case even
if you take that into account.
So in some sense, even if you're
aware of the planning fallacy,
and you plan, and you know that
people are going to-- things
are going to take longer,
somewhat oddly enough,
people are even
taking longer even
if you take that into account.
But anyway, so the
question is kind of
like how can we separate that.
I think, from this evidence,
we cannot separate this.
There are sort of like
cleaner experiments that
are more careful about this.
In some sense, if
it were just about
like underestimating
effort costs,
then you would not set your
own deadlines necessarily.
Like, the setting
early deadlines
is consistent with
self-control issues.
But just from the
performance, you're right.
That could just be people
underestimate effort costs as
well.
In general, I think this is hard
to separate in many situations.
The key part about the
self-control problems
about the time-inconsistent
is a demand for commitment
which sort of
reveals that people
have some form of
self-control problems related
to time preferences.
Any other question?
So now, there's one concern
is the two sessions are not
randomly assigned.
Why is that a
problem, potentially?
So we have, like, 51 executives.
25 or something-- 26 are
in one and 25 are another,
but they're not
randomly assigned
across the two sessions.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Well, if
you're just [INAUDIBLE]
you might want to pick the
class with the [INAUDIBLE]..
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right, so
there could be selection people
sort of switch sessions.
I am not sure recitations--
I'm not sure that's
actually possible.
But setting that-- so
that's surely one problem,
like, selection into
the different groups.
Setting that aside, what
other problem do we have?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
something like
if the two sessions
are at different times,
and there's some
advanced class that we
can see as one session
but not the other,
you could end up with
more advanced students
in [INAUDIBLE] section, which
could affect how good they
are at writing [INAUDIBLE].
FRANK SCHILBACH: Exactly,
there could just be other--
sorry, this is a version of
what you were saying earlier.
So I misunderstood a little bit.
Exactly, there could
be, like, people are--
for other reasons than
the actual treatment,
people might--
one session is early.
One is late.
One is on Thursday.
One is on Friday.
One has a better TA.
One has a worse TA, or whatever.
People might sort of select
into different-- so the
characteristics that people
have when they select into
or when they end up in
session A versus session B
might be different.
So what you compare is
essentially different types
of people.
Second, there's only two
sessions or sections.
That's essentially
an issue of, like,
sample size and statistics.
They're going to talk to
one of the recitations
about that in more detail.
But essentially, the bottom line
is that if you randomize, add--
or if you were to randomize,
which they haven't even
done here, but if
you were randomize
at the level of a section,
then if you only have,
like, two sections, that's
essentially not enough.
Because you might face
correlated shocks.
What is that?
For example, it
might be like one TA
is better than the other.
And one class, A or
B, the group might
do much better than the other,
not because of the deadline
policy, but just
because of the TA.
Or again, it could be that,
like, the recitation is
early in the morning, and
people don't pay attention,
or whatever.
There might be many other
things happening and so on.
So in some sense,
the sample size
is A, too small to start with.
50 people is very small
for an experiment.
Two, if you randomize or if you
have only, like, two treatment
groups, you need more
clusters, as people call it--
more sort of items of
randomization overall.
So now, there's a
second experiment
that they did sort of to
deal with the first issue.
This was sort of like,
again, not a huge sample,
but somewhat better.
It's 60 people.
And now, it's randomized
into three treatment groups.
One is evenly-spaced deadlines.
B is, like, no deadlines.
Three is, like,
self-imposed deadlines.
This is now a proofreading
exercise over 21 days.
This is now randomized
at the individual level,
so it's not in groups anymore.
So we get a little bit away
from this cluster issue
that we had before.
Now, what does an
exponential discounter
do in terms of performance?
What do we predict
what's going to happen?
So like, a person
with beta equals 1,
what do we say is
going to happen
to the performance
of these groups?
AUDIENCE: It should be the same?
FRANK SCHILBACH: Yes.
Which one?
All of them?
AUDIENCE: I'm not sure.
FRANK SCHILBACH: So let's start
with the self-imposed deadlines
and the no deadlines.
What kinds of deadlines is
the exponential discounter
going to set?
AUDIENCE: None?
FRANK SCHILBACH:
None, somebody said?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
FRANK SCHILBACH: Yes, and--
AUDIENCE: I don't think
they need the deadline.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Yeah, like,
why would you set a deadline?
You didn't need a deadline.
You're going to just do it
whenever it's best to do.
There might be some--
you might get sick
or, like, some other
shocks might appear
in the course of the semester.
So deadlines will just
restrict yourself.
So you will not
self-impose any deadlines.
So early deadlines essentially
just limit flexibility.
That's not helpful to do.
You don't need to sort of
self-impose any deadlines.
And then, you might sort
of do weekly worse--
in group A, you might do
it a little bit worse,
because essentially, shocks
might happen or the like.
There's no reason
to believe that,
like, if you restrict your
option, you might do better.
Group A might happen to do as
well as C and B. But at least
they are going to
be weekly worse,
in part because people get sick
around deadlines or the like.
OK?
So what about a sophisticated
person with beta hat
equals beta smaller than 1?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Self-imposed
deadlines should
equal evenly-spaced deadlines?
FRANK SCHILBACH: Can
you explain more?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
FRANK SCHILBACH: So the
evenly-spaced deadline
will do better or worse than
no deadlines, to start with?
AUDIENCE: They would do better?
FRANK SCHILBACH:
And why is that?
AUDIENCE: Because they--
if they have present bias,
then they'll procrastinate.
So then they would have three
things due at the same time.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Exactly.
Exactly, so that should help.
And then the self-imposed
deadlines, there,
you can optimally
set the deadlines,
so you could probably do
at least weekly better than
the evenly-spaced ones,
because you might also take
into account some constraints
that you have in a semester,
like your family is
visiting or the like,
that might be sort of--
so evenly-spaced
deadlines, some might not
be optimal because of that.
If you self-impose them and
you're perfectly sophisticated,
you can take that into account.
So deadlines can help.
And flexible deadlines
tend to be preferable,
because you can
take into account
your individual specific
costs that you might face.
OK, what about the
fully naive person?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So no deadlines
and self-imposed deadlines
should be the same.
Because if you're
fully naive, you
don't think you need that
much [INAUDIBLE] commitment
devices, so you just
set them to the end
as if you're expontential.
And evenly-spaced
should be weekly better,
because even if it's
not fully optimal,
it should stop some
of the [INAUDIBLE]..
FRANK SCHILBACH: Correct.
Correct, so as before, the
evenly-spaced deadlines,
since the person has beta
smaller-- or some people
have beta smaller than 1, the
evenly-spaced deadlines likely
do better, or help
people do better,
unless they sort of miss a lot
of deadlines anyway because
of procrastination.
But assuming the deadlines are
sort of helping people space
things out better,
they're going to do better
than the no deadlines case.
And then, the fully
naive person says,
why would I set any deadlines?
I don't need any deadline.
Flexibility is good.
I'm going to do it early anyway.
Of course, that's
not going to happen.
But then essentially, B
is doing the same as C,
because the person does not
set any deadlines at all, OK?
So now, what about the
partially naive person?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: A is better than
C which is better than B?
FRANK SCHILBACH:
Can you say more?
AUDIENCE: Sure,
so I mean, I guess
if they're sufficiently
sophisticated, then
it's is possible that Cis better
than A which is better than B.
But if they're mostly
naive, then they
will do some kind of
deadline imposition
which is not the absence of
deadlines in its entirety,
but it might not be as
good as [INAUDIBLE]..
FRANK SCHILBACH: So I
guess the answer is, like,
to some degree, it depends.
So we still have, like,
A is better than B.
So if people have
beta smaller than 1,
the evenly-spaced
deadlines still,
as before, are going
to do somewhat better
than the no deadlines.
Now, for the
self-imposed deadlines,
essentially two
things can happen.
One is, like, the
person might actually
set some deadlines that
happen to be actually helpful.
If they're sufficiently
sophisticated,
the deadlines might actually
help at least some people.
But for some people, they might
set overambitious deadlines
and say, oh, I'm going to
get it done all next week.
Well, it turns out
that's actually not true.
And then they sort of
said too-early deadlines
and then have to rush, or they
miss the deadline, or the like.
They might actually do worse.
So there, we have essentially
no clear predictions.
Some commitment should help.
So C could be better than B.
But individuals might also
overcommit.
So C might actually
be worse than B.
So that's-- essentially,
there's no empirical--
clear empirical prediction.
Any questions on what
I showed you here?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
FRANK SCHILBACH: Yeah.
FRANK SCHILBACH:
So you mean, like,
a subsample of people
who happen to choose
evenly-spaced deadlines?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: So the
concerns [INAUDIBLE]----
so I guess I'm just not sure
[INAUDIBLE] could that possibly
[INAUDIBLE] leave the
concerns that you [INAUDIBLE]..
FRANK SCHILBACH: Yeah, so the
issue there is essentially--
so one thing they were doing
in the paper is to say,
let's look at the people who
set evenly-spaced deadlines,
and say, when they--
how are they doing compared to
people in the control group,
or the like?
The problem with that
is, like, these people
are selected in certain ways.
Like, if I sort of just--
this is a subset of people
that's non-randomly selected.
We know that they chose
certain deadlines.
So in some sense, we know
that they're different,
in some ways, compared to the
average person in the group.
And these could be
people who are, like,
more productive, less
productive, et cetera, and so
on.
So the clean design,
how you would
do that is essentially,
what you would do is,
you would ask people to--
ask for their deadline
choices, and then
randomize them into
different deadline regimens.
So either they get
their choice or not.
So you can actually estimate
the treatment effect
on those kinds of
people, and then
look at are
evenly-spaced deadlines--
are those treatment effects
on those people worse or not?
But I worry that in
that kind of analysis,
what's non-random here--
or what they're choosing
as a non-random subset and
compare that with a control
group--
they're sort of-- that's
correlated with other stuff.
And that's not necessarily
getting your causal effect.
Having said that, when you look
at the evenly-spaced deadlines,
they could sort make
things worse in some ways,
in the sense of,
like, even for people
with beta smaller
than 1, it could
be that people
missed the deadlines
because they're procrastinating,
and so on, and so forth.
Or they had some
shocks and the like,
so it's not necessarily
obvious that they do better.
That's sort of all
under some assumptions.
Any other questions?
OK, so now, what
we find is, like,
A is doing better than C
is doing better than B.
So this essentially true
for errors detected.
It's true for delays
in submission.
It's also true for
people's earnings
in the entire exercise.
So now, what you have
is, like, A is better
than C is better than B. So
what is that consistent with?
Well, it seems like it's
consistent with some partial
naiveté.
In some sense, admittedly, the
prediction of partial naiveté
is a little bit loose
in a sense that, like,
all we're saying is A is
better than B. And you know,
then the comparison with
C could go either way.
So sure, it's consistent
with partial naiveté,
but it's also only
suggestive in some sense.
Because there's no clear
prediction in that case.
However, we can reject--
sort of like the other cases,
we can reject the
exponential discountings
of sophisticated present bias
to fully sophisticated one,
or the fully naive
present biased person,
because those predictions
are not borne out.
So the only case that really
is left is the partial naiveté
one.
So let me-- sort of to
summarize what we saw,
so the result is that deadline
setting improves performance,
that is evidence of some
present bias-- being essentially
beta being smaller than 1.
It's also consistent
with partial naiveté.
People set deadlines,
which is consistent.
They set early
deadlines, which shows
some demand for commitment,
some form of sophistication.
Then, result 2 says deadline
setting is suboptimal, which
sort of suggests that beta
is smaller than beta hat,
or beta hat is bigger than beta,
which means that essentially,
people seem to underestimate the
self-control problems that they
have in the future.
So that's, sort of
broadly speaking,
some support of the beta delta
model with partial naiveté.
Any questions on this paper?
OK.
Yes, sorry, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: I was confused by
what you meant by partial
sophistication or
partial naiveté.
FRANK SCHILBACH: So this is
what I was discussing earlier,
partial naivete
being-- meaning that--
let me just go
back for a second.
This is [INAUDIBLE]
discussing here earlier,
partial naiveté meaning that--
so we discussed
two cases before,
which was full naiveté
or full sophistication--
full naiveté meaning
that beta hat equals 1,
full sophistication meaning
that beta hat equals beta.
And now, if you sort of take
the case in between, which is--
where you see-- which I have
here at the bottom, which
is beta hat is in the
middle of beta and 1,
or in between beta and 1.
So essentially, you understand
that your beta in the future
is not 1.
But you sort of underestimate
how small it is.
So as I said before,
my beta might be 0.6.
I might understand my
future beta is not 1.
So I understand
it's smaller than 1.
But I might think it's,
like, 0.8 or 0.9, which
is to say I overestimate my
future beta to some degree.
While I get it right
that it's not 1,
I might sort of get
it wrong in the sense
of saying it's not 0.6.
In fact, I might think
it's higher than that.
OK.
OK, let me go back to--
OK, so in some sense,
these are nice experiments.
They're useful experiments
to help us sort of understand
is there evidence
for this model,
is there evidence for some of
the predictions that we have?
But it's still fairly
contrived in the sense of,
like, it's kind of
like-- especially
in the second experiment--
it's kind of like a lab
experiment and the like.
Really, what we want to
know is, in the real world,
are commitment devices
A, helpful in some sense?
Do people want them?
And B, are they
actually improving
behaviors in certain ways?
Should a firm use
commitment devices?
This is actually helpful for
improving firm performance.
So there's a very nice paper
by Supreet Kaur, Sendhil
Mullainathan, and
Michael Kremer,
who sort of investigate
this question using
data entry workers in India.
So this is a full-time
job for people.
This is the primary source of
earnings for these workers.
These are people who are sort of
recruited as data entry workers
for the course of 13
months-- so over a year--
as a typical data entry worker.
So in some sense, there
was a job ad that said,
we're looking for a
data entry worker.
We have data to be entered.
People would answer
the job ad and then
sort of start working
to do data entry.
Output is measured, as it is
usual done in many data entry
companies, by measuring
the number of accurate
fields entered in a day.
This is measured by doing dual
entry, as in to say the data
is entered twice.
It's then matched
with the other person.
And the number of
errors or discrepancies
are then defined
as an error rate.
And if the error rate--
you're matched to
different people over time,
so I can sort of back
out your error rate--
how good or bad you are.
So people are
essentially incentivized
to do to work fast,
and incentivized
to enter stuff correctly.
Workers are paid a piece rate
using the weekly paycheck that
paid once a week.
There's no
restrictions on hours.
People can show up
whenever they like.
They can stay for as many hours
as they like on any given day.
There are no penalties
for absences.
So you can just-- if you
don't show up on a given day,
nothing happens.
This is what the data
entry task looks like.
There's essentially some data.
This is kind of interesting.
This is data coming from Kenya.
So Michael Kremer and
Sendhil Mullainathan
were working on some
Kenyan data where
they had a huge amount of data
from Kenyan sugarcane farmers
over the course of 30 years--
some historical records
that they found.
They wanted them to get entered.
So like, how do we
get them entered?
Well, India is the
place to do that.
So they got them entered.
And then, when they hired lots
of people to enter the data,
they thought, well, why
not run an experiment
to learn about self-control
among workers while doing that?
So what they would do is they
would show these scanned images
of these pages.
And then there's like a computer
software, pretty rudimentary,
where you can sort of enter
the fields in your data set.
Now, the commitment device
is a dominated contract
that looks as follows.
So the-- as I told
you before, workers
are paid a piece rate w.
It's a linear piece rate.
That's the control contract
for their production.
So forever production, think
of production as how much
the correct entries
that you produce.
For each correct
entry that you make,
you're going to get paid w.
Now, the dominated
contract looks as this--
this is the red one
that you see here--
which is until a
target T. We'll talk
about the target in a second.
Until the target T, you
paid w over 2, which
is like half as much as before.
And as soon as you
reach T, the target,
you're going to be paid w
for the entire production
that you make.
Why is this a
commitment contract?
So if I ask you to
choose your target T,
if you choose a
positive target, why
is this a commitment contract?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So if you
go less then you're
penalized for it by making
less money [INAUDIBLE]..
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right.
That's right.
So there's no value of
choosing this contract.
So if you are an
exponential discounter,
you might just
choose T equals 0,
the reason being that
there's no point in choosing
a high target.
Who knows what's
going to happen?
You might get a headache.
Your kid might get sick.
The computer might
not work, or whatever.
For whatever reason,
there might be
shocks, uncertainty that might
make you not reach your target.
And so if you choose a positive
target, the only thing you
can do from this positive
target is, you see,
you can do only worse, right?
It's a weakly dominated contract
in terms of your payments,
so there's no reason
to actually do that.
But why might the worker
actually choose it anyway?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Because
earlier, you specified
that the workers can
come and go as they
please once they get to work.
And so there's no
real set schedule.
So [INAUDIBLE] or think that
they know themselves, and think
that they'll push off all
the work until the very
last minute, et
cetera, et cetera.
And so they might want
the commitment device
to incentivize themselves to
finish their work [INAUDIBLE]..
FRANK SCHILBACH: Exactly,
I might sort of just
be slightly below T or the like.
I might sort of be
tempted to go home.
You know, my friends
call or whatever,
and I might just
not want to do it.
It might be just a tedious day.
It might be really hot.
I had really goals
to work a lot,
and I want to incentivize
my future self
to reach certain targets.
That's exactly right.
So I think this is--
we've already said all of that.
Workers can choose
the T in advance.
They can choose-- essentially,
on the previous day,
they can choose T equals 0.
They also have
randomization of paydays
to be able to look
at payday effects.
What do I mean by that?
I told you, like,
workers are paid weekly.
And so they randomize
the paydays.
What they do is they randomize
the pages to be Tuesdays,
Thursdays, or Saturdays
so that you can allow
for day-of-the-week
fixed effects.
That's kind of
[INAUDIBLE] interesting.
But essentially,
you can look at,
when a worker is
paid in a given week,
are they more or less
productive on that day compared
to the previous days,
and so on and so forth.
What does the exponential
discounting model
predict about paydays
or payday effects?
Should you work
harder on a payday?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: No, because
you're time-consistent.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right, exactly.
Like, your delta is
0.95 or the like.
It doesn't really matter whether
the daily discounting should
be essentially
close-- there should
be essentially close
to no discounting
between different days.
You might have a yearly
delta of 0.95 or the like.
But then, between today
and tomorrow, or two days
and three days from now and so
on, it doesn't really matter.
So if I'm working today
and I'm paid today,
it's the same as if
I'm working today
and I'm paid in like three days.
However, if I'm a
quasi-hyperbolic discounter,
well, what's going to
be the case is, like,
if I'm working on
Sundays, I'm working today
and I'm going to be paid today.
Well, then I'm going
to go work harder.
Maybe I get the
money right away.
I can buy a nice
meal, my family is
going to be happier,
and so on and so forth.
Now notice, that requires some
form of liquidity constraints,
right?
In the sense that if I have
a bunch of cash anyway,
it doesn't really
matter whether I'm
going to be paid
today versus tomorrow.
But assuming that some workers
are liquidity constrained,
essentially whether
they're paid today
versus tomorrow matters a
lot when the reward comes.
If you think about today,
it's like 10:00 AM.
I'm typing and typing.
Now, I think about, like,
when do I get the reward.
Either it's on
the payday, you're
going to be paid
at, like, 5:00 PM,
so you're going to get
essentially a nice meal
on the same day.
Versus if you're paid in five
days, that's really far away.
In the beta delta world,
your reward for working hard
is coming much later, OK?
So you would think
quasi-hyperbolic discounters
would put in higher
efforts on paydays.
Assuming there is some form
of liquidity constraints,
there should be close to no
difference between other days.
That depends a little bit, like,
what's the horizon of the beta
that we talked about before.
OK, so now what do they
find in this paper?
They find essentially
three results.
The first result is there's
demand for commitment.
There's sort of-- people
choose dominated contracts.
That is to say, workers
select dominated contracts
about 36% of the time.
This is a lower bound
for the extent of time
inconsistency for three reasons.
Reason one is some
workers might be naive.
They might sort of think
they don't need any targets.
Well, in fact, they would
benefit from targets.
Or they might underinvest
in this technology.
Second, people might think this
commitment device is actually
ineffective, in a
sense saying, look,
this is sort of what we're
talking about with the Frog
and the Toad.
There might be-- they might
have time-inconsistency issues.
It might just not be a strong
enough commitment device.
And so then, if I have
a day where I just
don't want to work, then if
that's not going to get you
over the target,
well then I might not
choose this commitment
device, not because I'm not--
I don't have present bias,
but because it's just
not effective enough of a
punishment for me to do.
Number three is people
might prefer flexibility
and they're risk-averse.
These are issues like they might
have children that get sick,
they might have
headaches, and so on.
They might just be risks that's
unrelated to their present bias
and the like.
The computers might be bad.
So they had different
computers at different speed.
You might end up with
a really bad computer,
and then you might
not reach the target.
That's nothing to do with
self-control or present bias,
but rather with sort
of external risk.
If you're really
worried about risk,
then you might not choose
a positive target either.
Second, they find offering the
dominated contracts increases
output.
That is to say, if you compare
groups that were, on some days,
offered those contracts,
compared to other groups that
were randomly selected
to be not offered
those contracts on
those same days,
they find that being offered
this commitment contract
increases production by 2.3%.
Now you might say 2%
is actually pretty low.
And that's true
in absolute terms.
That's not a lot of money.
But if you think about
what other options does
the employer have,
well, one thing
you might want to do to
increase worker's output
is sort of a double their wages
or just increase wages overall.
Now it turns out that they also
have some piece rate variations
where they can actually estimate
how much of a piece rate
increase do we need to achieve
these effects on productivity.
And it turns out, the
impact is actually
corresponding to, like, an
18% increase in the piece rate
wage.
Now, if you're an
employer, you don't
want to pay people,
like, an 80% higher piece
rate for, like, a 2% or 3%
increase in productivity.
That's just not worth doing.
It's just like a bad deal.
I mean, depends a little bit
on your costs and benefits
of production.
But that's a very
ineffective way
of getting workers to
be more productive,
and it's a costly thing to do.
You're going to incentivize a
bunch of intramarginal people
to do that.
Instead, offering commitment
devices in this setting
is actually free.
And in some sense,
for the employer,
you might actually
pay people less.
Some people don't
reach a target,
you can actually pay w over 2.
Now, you actually
don't want to do that,
because workers will be
not happy and, you know,
probably get annoyed with
you if you do that too much.
But the technology
is actually free.
Here's a thing that you
can offer to your workers.
They're going to be 2%
to 3% more productive.
That's actually a big deal
for a lot of companies,
in terms of the margins
are often small,
and a much better instrument
and getting workers
to be more productive compared
to increasing people's wages.
Because wages, obviously,
you need to pay.
Any questions on that?
And then a third--
and this is sort of
consistent with a model
of self-control control
being really the
driver of this--
is payday effects predict
people's demand for commitment.
I'm going to show
you this in a second.
But essentially, what
they find is that they're
A-- they're payday effects.
What do I mean by that?
If you plot, essentially,
production over the course
of the day cycle--
so here's-- on the very right
hand side of this graph,
you see people's payday
productivity compared
to the productivity on
the day after the payday,
or seven days before the payday.
You'll see people essentially
are more productive on payday.
They produce more
on paydays compared
to, like, previous days.
And so that what you
see, essentially,
is a constant increase
towards the day of the payday.
Now, somebody was
asking me previously
about quasi-hyperbolic
discounting,
or hyperbolic discounting,
which model is right.
When you look at this
graph, this actually
doesn't look very much like
quasi-hyperbolic discounting.
It looks a lot more like
hyperbolic discounting,
as in, like, there's sort
of like a smooth increase.
There's not a jump up.
On the day of the payday
people are more productive,
but it's rather sort
of more consistent
with true hyperbolic
discounting.
That's more of a detail here.
That's not that
important for you.
But I wanted to point that out.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: What's the scale
and unit on the y-axis?
FRANK SCHILBACH: That
is a great question.
I think its production.
So I think this is not a--
this is not a great--
I think these are
units of production.
I don't know exactly
what the fraction
is in terms of production.
But it must be, like, a
few percent of production.
I can look this up.
But it's like units
of production,
which is surely not what
you want to use here.
Yeah, and so then--
so what we find here is
that, essentially, people
are more productive
on paydays compared
to the day after the payday,
or compared to, like, six days
before the payday.
And then we find
another graph, which
is a quite nice one, which is
to say high payday workers,
or high payday effect workers,
are more likely to select
positive targets.
What I mean by that is
they split the sample
into workers who have high
payday impacts and low payday
impacts.
That is to say, when you look
at the workers and look at,
like, which workers are more
productive on paydays compared
to on other days, you can sort
of split the sample into two.
Some workers are
much more productive
on paydays compared
to other days.
Some workers are not.
So what you see here in
the graph is you see,
essentially, the blue dots.
These are workers who
have high payday impacts.
These are workers who are much
more productive on paydays
compared to other days.
And you see the red
dots, which are workers
who are, essentially,
pretty much
they have low payday
impact, meaning
they kind of work the same on
paydays versus on other days.
And then what they show on
the-- so then, on the x-axis,
they show experience.
This is essentially--
think of this
as the course of the study.
These are something
like 150 days.
They have different workdays
in the sample, where
essentially, over time,
people get to choose
over and over their targets.
And what you see, essentially,
is that the blue graph--
the blue dots tend to be A,
higher than the red graphs,
meaning that people have
high payday impacts.
These are workers of
high payday effects.
They're like more
productive on paydays.
They're more likely to
choose positive targets.
Sorry, I should have
said, on the y-axis,
you see the fraction of people
choosing positive targets, OK?
So what we see
essentially is two things.
One is the blue dots are
higher than the red dots,
meaning that the people
have high payday impacts.
They are more likely to
choose positive targets, sort
of suggesting that
the underlying reason
why people have high payday
impact is self-control.
You're more, essentially,
productive on paydays
because you're present
biased one way or the other.
And that also then predicts
whether you choose the target.
So people who have higher
self-control problems as
revealed by the
payday effects, those
are the people who are
more likely to choose
positive targets.
Second, we also see
that the blue dots
tend to be trending
upwards in the graph.
You see on the
right, the blue dots
are higher than on
the left in the graph,
meaning that as people have more
experience in the study, when
they have like 100,
150 days in the study,
they're more likely to
choose positive targets,
consistent with some learning
about self-control over time.
So they learn over time that
choosing positive targets
is a good thing for
them, potentially, that
makes them more productive.
You don't see such a
thing for the red dots
that seem to be essentially
flat or constant over time.
Sorry, that was a
lot of information.
Are there any questions on that?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Arguably,
there's lots to do
with the savings of
the payday, right?
So on the payday, I have
to come in to the office
and do the work.
So I might as well type a little
longer to earn a little more.
Another is you don't
really have an incentive.
They're not getting paid.
So there are other
jobs where you
get paid at the end
of the day, every day.
And then you don't really
find the payday effects
in those kinds of jobs, right?
FRANK SCHILBACH:
Right, so exactly.
So there's an issue
on, when you think
about these payday effects, what
exactly do we learn from that?
One way to think about
the payday effects
is kind of like the
story I was telling you,
which is to say, on days when
you come in, when you type,
when you work, you're going
to be paid in the evening.
And you're going to work
harder, because your reward is
closer to you--
to your effort.
Another explanation
that you were saying
is like, well, what
if workers are just,
like, liquidity constrained.
What if their children are
hungry, et cetera, and so on.
So you come in on that day
because you want a paycheck.
Once you show up anyway, you
might as well do some work.
And you're going to end up
being more productive that way.
That's surely, in
part, going on.
I have sort of two
responses to that.
So one response is, like, well,
we find that the workers with
high payday impacts are more
likely to choose positive
targets, which sort of suggests
there is an underlying issue
which is self-control problems
that drives both the payday
effects and the high--
the positive targets
that people choose
to demand for commitment.
Second, and more subtle in
some ways, is, like, people
are liquidity constrained.
People who don't
have cash, there's
often a reason why
they don't have
cash, which is often
because they haven't
saved in the first place.
Again, that's a
little complicated.
But essentially, if somebody
is very liquidity constrained,
never has cash,
often that's coming--
or the underlying
reason might be
present bias, or some form
of self-control problems
to start with.
The reason being that,
like, if you really
had such a value-- high
value of having cash,
you should just save it
and have it in your home,
or try to save money in
a bank account and so on.
So usually, we think that
when people are really
liquidity constrained,
often that's
an underlying reason
of present bias
or some form of
self-control problems.
Having said that, there's
also some other reasons
why people can't save.
Because it might be they don't
have access to bank accounts,
and so on, and so forth.
OK.
OK, so let me tell you
one more application.
And let me sort of continue
with the rest of those tomorrow.
So this is sort of like
a classic study, in fact,
done in Boston in Boston
area health clubs.
So this is Dellavigna
and Malmendier.
And what they did is they
looked at health clubs
and different
options that people
did in gyms when they had
choices between the following,
or the following kind, which
is monthly fees of over $70
for unlimited use of the gym,
or a pay-per-visit fee of $10.
If you had that option
or those two options,
which options would you choose?
Or why would you choose
one or the other?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: If you
think you're going
to use the gym more than seven
times in a month, [INAUDIBLE]..
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right, exactly.
So why pay more than-- why pick
option number one if you only
go three times?
When I was teaching
the first time,
I was doing exactly
that, in fact.
But exactly as you
say, if you make--
if you understand how
often you go to the gym,
why choose option one if you
don't go at least seven times?
There could be some
transaction costs and the like.
But surely, if you go
only once or twice,
you should not
choose option one.
Now of course, some people
might choose option one anyway.
Why might you do that?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Would it be
for a commitment device?
Like, I would pay for
this month [INAUDIBLE]
I want to get my money's worth.
FRANK SCHILBACH:
Right, So one option
is, like, essentially
change their future prices.
So notice that the marginal cost
of going to the gym in option
two is $10, right?
Every time you go, your
marginal cost is $10.
In option one, the
marginal cost is 0.
So what I'm trying to do
is change the marginal cost
in the future to make it
more favorable for me to go.
What else could be going on?
So one is they could use
this as a commitment device.
What's another explanation?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Overestimation of
how many times you would go?
FRANK SCHILBACH: Exactly, it
could be like, essentially--
and there's two
versions of that.
One version has to do with beta
delta or present bias, which
is to say I'm just
underestimating
my future present bias.
I think my beta is, like,
1, but in fact, it's 0.5.
I think I'm going
to go 17 times,
but in fact, I'm
going only twice.
That's one option.
Another option that was
also mentioned earlier
was about, like, underestimating
the costs of future exercising.
That is to say,
what often happens
when people sign up
for the gym, often
they are already at the gym.
They are really excited
to exercise, and so on.
And they might underestimate
how costly it actually
is once they sit at
home in the evening
coming back home
from work and so on.
They might underestimate how
it feels, how costly it is
for them to actually exercise.
Nothing to do with
self-control specifically,
but it's just it's a
tedious thing to do.
They might
underestimate how tired
they are, and so on,
and so forth-- so
some form of like
underestimation of the cost.
That's, again, hard to
separate in many cases.
But that could also be going on.
So what they find then is people
exercise, on average, 4.3 times
a month in the first year.
That's about $17 per visit.
And of course, you should
be choosing option two.
Before canceling, consumers
go 2.3 months, on average,
without using the
gym at all, which
is kind of like it's even
tedious to cancel the gym
and actually go there.
And I did, actually,
exactly that as well.
And so how do we think about
quasi-hyperbolic discounting
here?
Well, the gym-goers
would like to exercise
a lot in the future.
Being naive, that's
what they think
they will do, so, you know,
overestimate what they will do.
To save on gym costs, they
buy the monthly membership.
So that's kind of what
the naive person does.
When it comes down
to exercising,
their short-run
inpatient kicks in,
and they do end up ending
the membership much.
That's very much like
sort of underestimating
or overestimating their
beta or underestimating
their self-control problem.
Now, what does the
sophisticated person do?
We already discussed that
as well, which is they also
prefer to exercise
a lot in the future,
but they realize they
don't want to do so later.
So what they want to do is they
choose the monthly contract
as a form of commitment
device, in the sense of,
like, making future actions
changing prices in the future,
they make it now cheaper
to exercise compared
to sit at home by sort of
changing the marginal costs
in the future.
And they might even be
willing to pay for that.
So they might
actually say, I know
that I'm only going to go
like three or four times.
But if I don't
choose that contract,
I'm going to only go 0 or 1
times, and it's worth for me
to do that.
So now, there's a
different version
of-- in which one
could do a commitment
devices about dealing
with temptation, which
is a very clever bundling of
temptations paper by Milkman
and others.
What they did-- instead of
offering commitment devices
directly, what they did
is they bundle two things.
I told you previously about
investment goods and leisure
goods.
And so investment goods are
things like going to the gym
that you do not enough of.
Leisure goods are things
that you enjoy in the present
and you might do
too much of that.
So now, what you can
do is you essentially
bundle those things.
So what they did is they offered
people the option to only
listen to audiobooks--
addictive audiobooks--
at the gym.
And so then, you
can only sort of
do that while you're at the gym.
And you might come
back to the gym,
not necessarily because
you want to exercise,
but because you want to
listen to your audiobook.
This can also backfire.
I have a friend of mine,
also in grad school, who
was watching lots of TV shows.
And he convinced himself that
he could only watch TV shows
while being at the gym.
So then, I would
be in the office,
and he would sometimes come back
from the gym totally exhausted
because he had watched like
three episodes of certain TV
shows while being
on the treadmill.
And so he was kind of
like overexercising
because of his consumption--
his bundling of temptations.
But in this case, for--
so you have to sort of figure
out how to calibrate this,
right?
But it could be a way of
getting you, essentially,
to-- by bundling, essentially,
pleasant and unpleasant things
at different points in time, by
bundling them in certain ways,
it might make you-- sort
of help you overcome
two issues at the time, which
is one, you go to the gym
more often.
B, you might not sort
of watch too much TV
if you can convince yourself
to actually follow through.
They do find, in fact,
bundling of temptation
is effective until
the Thanksgiving
break, when sort of everything
goes downhill in their study.
OK, that's all I have for now.
I'm going to continue on
tomorrow with the remaining
parts of time preferences.
Thank you.